er ist der größte planet des
sonnensystems und hat 300 mal so viel
masse wie die erde doch wie der jupiter
entstanden sein könnte davon hatte die
wissenschaft bisher kaum eine ahnung
oder wusste vieles entscheidendes nicht
ein forschungsteam aus zürich hat dazu
jetzt ein neues modell entwickelt mit
super spannenden erkenntnissen klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
angefangen hatte alles mit daten von
meteoriten die im vergangenen jahr auf
einer amerikanischen konferenz
vorgestellt worden waren
die analyse der isotope ließ damals
nämlich darauf schließen dass unser
sonnensystem in seiner uhrzeit in zwei
regionen aus staub und gas aufgeteilt
war das etwa zwei millionen jahre lang
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit schlossen aus dieser
beobachtung dass der gasriese jupiter
damals ein als eine art teilende
barriere für das sonnensystem diente
dabei störte er offenbar die
staubscheibe und erzeugte so eine über
dichtung konkret konnte sich das
material außerhalb seiner umlaufbahn
nicht mit dem material das sich
innerhalb seiner umlaufbahn befand
vermischen in diesem 2 millionen jahren
wuchs der jupiter wohl von 20 auf 50
erdmassen und die trennung und seine
barrierefunktion wurde aufgehoben als
der junge planet so viel masse
angereichert hatte im gestein um zu
lenken so konnte es auch in die inneren
regionen des sonnensystems gelangen zu
dieser hypothese passt auch das neue
modell des schweizerischen
forschungsteams das nähere infos zu der
entstehung des jupiters herausfinden
konnte demnach ist der gasriese in
verschiedenen phasen gewachsen der
planeten embryo hat also zunächst
zentimeter große kieselsteine
angesammelt und so innerhalb von einer
million jahren einen kern gebildet die
darauf folgenden zwei millionen jahre
verliefen etwas entspannter hier wurde
der aktuellen studie zufolge kilometer
große planeten sie male angehäuft also
so werden die bausteine und vorläufer
vom planeten genannt dieser prozess
setze
sehr viel wärme frei denn die risiken
objekte trafen den immer größer
werdenden planeten mit gigantischer
wucht dazu einer der forscher jan albert
von der universität
während der ersten etappe brachten die
kieselsteine die masse in der zweiten
phase fügten die planeten sie male auch
etwas masse hinzu aber was noch
wichtiger ist sie brachten energie nach
drei millionen jahren hatte der jupiter
somit 50 mal so viel masse wie die erde
dann begann die dritte phase seiner
entwicklung in der sich gas anreicherte
heute verfügt der gasriese über 300 mal
so viel masse wie die erde
das modell zeigt also dass der jupiter
sich phasenweise deutlich langsamer
entwickelt hat als man bislang
angenommen hatte
dem gängigen modell zufolge nämlich
hatte sich zunächst durch die ansammlung
zentimeter großer gesteins körper der
planeten kern gebildet als dieser die
masse von 20 erdmassen überschritt
sorgte die schwerkraft dafür dass gas
aus der umgebung aufgenommen wurde
dadurch wiederum wurde bislang ein sich
selbst verstärkender extrem rasantes
anwachsen des planeten erklärt noch das
modell des schweizerischen
forschungsteams konnte jetzt auch zeigen
wodurch genau dieses schnelle anwachsen
also was man bisher vermutet
verhindert wurde demnach hat sich der
entstehende planet extrem heiß
aufgeheizt und zwar durch die eben
erwähnten schweren einschläge kilometer
großer gesteins körper der planeten sie
male in dieser phase herrschte eine
extreme temperatur die dafür gesorgt hat
dass der jupiter keine leichten gaza
haben sich binden konnte
dass es auch die erklärung dafür warum
es zwei millionen jahre gedauert hat bis
der jupiter von 20 auf 50 erdmassen
angewachsen ist das forschungsteam ist
jetzt optimistisch dass diese ergebnisse
auch helfen können rätsel rund um die
entstehung von exoplaneten sowie von
neptun und uranus zu lösen und jetzt
clixoom wird werbefrei keine primär mit
eurer hilfe immer wenn wir entsprechend
viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben
schalten wir die werbung für jeweils
einem video im monat ab bald ist es beim
ersten video soweit werdet also mitglied
hier unter dem video draufklicken also
hier drunter und bekommt dazu noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live
streams wie kommenden dienstag und noch
ein paar weitere privilegien die sehr
lustig unter anderem sind ein riesen
dank an alle diejenigen die schon dabei
sind absolute hammer es werden immer
mehr
wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informiert werden wollt dann
hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann
bekommt ihr den link zum video vor allen
an
von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo vergessen und natürlich
nicht zu vergessen auf die genau glocke
zu klicken
ja und hier geht es weiter mit also hier
neue jupiter fakten der raumsonde juno
bis dann bleibt dran